a bull is going after them and they've
signed up for this yeah and someone has
told them if you can get this red thing
off the Bull's Head you'll be married
next just this woman gets just trapped I
destroyed what are we doing she now
can't she lost both of her ovaries with
that shot Mike why are people doing this
why are they running towards the bull
you've had bachelorette parties at your
comedy shows yeah I I think the answer
is probably alcohol thank you probably
alcohol like this is deer alcohol here's
what happens because he and and again
people are running towards this and
other people are cheering it these are
people's daughters two hundred dollars
that's what you win it's not so it
should be two thousand dollars okay it
should be your medical bills paid for it
should be and here they go and again no
one's going at Bully's going after
everybody and again a lot of people in
jeans I'm gonna guess a lot of women are
like this was a terrible mistake
destroyed
[Music]